أعني أنه نوع من الصدمة أنك
تعرف أن هذه الأنواع من الصور نادرة
بما يكفي في عام 2022
لدرجة أنها في الواقع أصبحت
فيروسية ، هل فوجئت برد العالم
على هذا ،
لقد فوجئت بالفعل لأنني
فعلت بعض الرسوم التوضيحية
التي لا تزال موجودة بالفعل  على بشرة سوداء لم
يكن ذلك فيروسيًا ، لذلك
فوجئت ولكن لدرجة أن هذا
الرسم سيكون له صدى لدى الناس
وكان علي أن أسأل نفسي بضعة أسئلة
لماذا كان هذا الرسم قادرًا على
صدى الناس لأنه بصراحة
لم يكن القصد أن ينتشر فيروسيًا ، فمن
المحتمل أن يكونوا مشهورين أو
أن أجعل حلمي يتحسن ولكن
لتمثيل السود لذلك كان علي أن
أسأل نفسي لماذا كان هذا الرسم فيروسيًا
ومن ثم فهمت ذلك  كان عليه أن
يتحدث في ذلك كان يتحدث في
قلب النساء ، قلب الأمهات اللائي عانين
من
تفاوتات الرعاية الصحية وما ذهب
إلى الكثير من الفوارق العرقية
لأنهن ببساطة من السود ، ومما يثير دهشتي
أنه كان كذلك  مندهش تمامًا من
المدى الذي قد يصل إليه هذا الاستنزاف
بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين ليسوا من السود الذين
ليسوا من الأقليات ، كيف تشرح
سبب
أهمية التمثيل المتكافئ في الأدبيات الطبية ،
إنه في الواقع مهم جدًا
لأننا نسير نحو الدمج المناسب
نحن نقود  نحو إنشاء
تغطية صحية شاملة حيث
يتلقى كل فرد رعاية صحية عادلة يتلقى رعاية
صحية متساوية
والسؤال هو ما إذا كان هذا هو الهدف ،
فما هو النهج لتحقيق
ذلك لأنه إذا لم يكن النهج
شاملاً للغاية إذا لم يكن هناك تمثيل مناسب ،
فكيف يتم ذلك  نحن
نعمل من أجل
تحقيق تغطية صحية شاملة
حيث تلقى الجميع اهتمامًا صحيًا متساويًا ،
لذا فإن هدفه الأساسي هو تضمين
الأشخاص الآخرين من الآسيويين والأسبان ، لذلك
لأنني شخص أسود ، فأنا
أتحدث نيابة عن السود وإذا كنت  كان
آسيويًا ، كنت أتحدث نيابة عن الآسيويين ، لذا
فإن هدفه ليس فقط
التأكيد على  r فقط للأشخاص السود
ولكن بالنسبة لأولئك الأشخاص الذين لم يتم
تمثيلهم بشكل كبير ، هناك حاجة
لتمثيلهم لأنني
أدركت أن
هناك الكثير من ظروف التفكير التي
تمثل بشكل مختلف على الجلد الآسيوي
أو على جلد ألبينو وهذا هو السبب
التمثيل بالطبع
مهم حقًا لأننا نحتاج إلى أن
نقول بدقة ونتأكد من
أن الجميع مهم